you're older you're wiser what's the
meaning of life George hotz
to win it's still to win of course
always of course what's winning look
like for you
oh I haven't figured out what the game
is yet but when I do so it's bigger than
solving self-driving it's bigger than
uh the market democratizing
decentralizing compute
I think the game is to stand eye to eye
with God
I wonder what that means for you like at
the end of your life what that will look
like
I mean this is what like I don't know
this is some this is some
there's probably some ego trip of mine
you know like if you want to stand eye
to eye with God it was just Blasphemous
man okay I don't know I don't know I
don't know if it would have said God
I think he like wants that I mean I
certainly want that for my creations
I want my Creations to stand eye to eye
with me
so why wouldn't God want me to stand eye
to eye with him
that's the best I can do golden rule
I'm just imagining the creator of a
video game
having to uh
look
stand eye to eye with one of the
characters
I only watched season one of Westworld
but yeah we gotta find the Maze and
solve it like
yeah I wonder what that looks like it
feels like a really special time in
human history
where that's actually possible like
there's something about AI That's like
we're playing with something weird here
something really weird I wrote a blog
post uh I reread Genesis and just looked
like they give you some Clues at the
endogenesis for finding the Garden of
Eden
and I'm interested
I'm interested uh well I hope you find
just that George you're one of my
favorite people thank you for doing
everything you're doing and in this case
for fighting for open source or for
decentralization of AI it's a it's a
fight Worth Fighting fight worth winning
hashtag
um I love you brother these
conversations are always great hope to
talk to you many more times good luck
with tiny Corp thank you great to be
here